welcome everyone
thank you for joining us for day two of
thermo fisher
asia pacific japan genetic solution
tour 2020 my name is ray
and i'm your moderator for this session
we will be kicking off today's events
by continuing various genetic analysis
solutions
for sun core 2 research
as well as various emerging applications
in this area of research
first of all we would like we will hear
from dr rachel formosa
who is senior director of global market
development
for the genetic sciences division of
thermo fisher scientific
her focus is on solutions that span
real-time pcr microarray
and sequencing technologies
rachel has developed expertise in these
technologies
over her 20 years of experience with
genetic analysis technologies
including the past 10 years with applied
biosystem products
and thermal fusion scientific
for complete biography on our speaker
please visit the tab at the top of your
screen
today she will talk about genetic
analysis solution
for star core v2 research
focusing on application in vaccine
research
and population studies
if any questions arise during the
presentation
we encourage you to submit them in the q
a box
our speaker will address your questions
following her presentation
now please join me in welcoming rachel
and i will turn the presentation over to
her
thank you for the introduction welcome
to day two of our genetic solutions tour
2020.
i'll kick off our question today about
genetic analysis solutions for thyroid
cov2 research focusing
on applications and vaccine research and
host genetics and population genomics
studies
as you heard yesterday thermo fisher
scientific has a history of response and
public health crises
we've worked hard to make a difference
during this current stars code vq
outbreak
as well as the previous outbreaks of
ebola h1n1
sars and zika and while we're talking
about our genetic analysis solutions for
outbreak research today
thermo fisher also provides protective
equipment
other scientific research tools like
those for protein and cellular analysis
diagnostic tests and vaccine production
and clinical trial logistics
this is fueled by our mission to make
the world healthier cleaner and safer
with our industry-leading scale and
unmatched depth of capability
as you know researchers around the world
are diligently working to gain a better
understanding of the novel coronavirus
with the goal of rapidly identifying
future treatment options and possible
vaccine targets
we know this research can't wait and
with a comprehensive portfolio genetic
analysis
thermo fisher scientific is your trusted
partner for virus discovery
pathogen detection epidemiological
surveillance
vaccine development and host genetics to
advance your research
to support these efforts we have a broad
range of technologies for genetic
analysis
including next generation sequencing
finger sequencing and fragment analysis
by capillary
electrophoresis microarrays both whole
genome genotyping as well as full
transcriptome arrays
and of course real-time pcr since you've
heard a little bit about our sequencing
technologies and the kickoff yesterday
i'm going to provide a bit more
background on our microarray and qthro
platforms before talking about specific
applications
today
so first our real-time pcr solutions
this represents over 25 years of
innovation
here we show our cloud studio family of
real-time pcr instruments which is our
latest
innovations in competitor
instrumentation
software sensitive specific detection
and quantification
of nucleic acid targets we also have a
suite of analysis software
as well as consumables to keep their
master mixes
and pac-man assays to power your
outbreak research study
in addition our microarray portfolio
enables rapid epidemiological studies
we have a wide portfolio of instruments
arrays and free analysis software for
both full genome genotyping
and post-transcription analysis
now i want to get into some more detail
about application areas
you heard about several key application
areas in the kickoff yesterday around
virus discovery and sequencing viral
detection and epidemiological
surveillance research
today i'm going to talk about two areas
vaccine research and post genetics and
population genomics studies
with these areas i'll describe which of
our genomic analysis technologies
and solutions can help you in your
research
first i'm going to talk about vaccine
research the aim here is to identify
protective antigen
and study the impact of infection of
potential vaccines on immune response
before we start we'll review a little
bit about our ion torrent next
generation sequencing portfolio
our bass easy platform offers end-to-end
workflows ideal for infectious disease
research studies that go beyond single
gene analysis
a simple scalable and highly automated
targeted envious solutions enable
discoveries in viral research
host response and vaccine research with
the same chemistry and platform
which allows igs to be more accessible
than ever before
it's clear that there's a varied
response as far as kovi to infection and
one question top of mind is what is
driving that variability
as well as how that might influence
future potential therapies or vaccine
response
human immune systems are complex one of
the drivers of that complexity is vbj
recombination
within immune system that creates
millions of different b and t
cell receptor sequences each encoding
for antigen specificity
better understanding of the repertoire
of t cell receptors and b
cell receptors within a single
individual or across the given
population will be key to developing new
potential therapies
both innate immunity and adaptive
immunity seem to play a role and are
important as far as cov2 research
enabling better understanding of both
response to infection
as well as to help predict response to
future treatments such as vaccines
study potential adverse effects or
quantify immune responses to
vaccinations
we've enabled a multidimensional view of
t t-cell and v-cell repertoires
delivering accurate cpr and v-thera
frequency to assess and quantify immune
response for vaccine research
multiple analyses are enabled to use
using our simple-to-use and highly
differentiated information suite from
diversity to clone inactivity
from diversity clone of activation
lineage analysis
and prediction of zero conversion
all areas highly relevant to better
understanding startup cov2
solutions for both human samples and
mouse models are enabled
when studying responsive vaccines it's
not just the immune system cells that
are potential biomarkers for response to
physiotherapy
current research is highlighting
aberrant responsive and immune response
and inflammatory pathways that will be
important to understand in relation to
vaccine response as well
i am amplifying human transcription gene
expression analysis
offered with fast affordable workflow to
profile over twenty thousand roughly
transcripts for biomarker identification
another emerging area of interest the
following findings in the field of
immunology that gut microbiome plays an
important role
in response to targeted therapies or
cancer vaccines and will therefore be
critical
in understanding response to future
startup cov2 vaccines as well
recent findings include the role of the
gut microbiome associated with in
association with disease severity
how dysbiosis can be linked to secondary
infections post-starved covaq
and the antibody response alters with
different microbiome profiles
the ion athletic microbiome health
research aspect is a targeted approach
for accurate cost-effective species
level profiling
gene expression microarrays are also
used for vaccine research
to study host virus interaction and
immune response
our clarion solution allows you to look
at the full transcriptome while our
clarion sra detect exons only
but depending on your depth and
throughput needs we have a microarray
solution that covers your vaccine
research studies as well
one example of that is using gene
expression arrays to look at the
expression of h2
and human lung tissue across different
subpopulations
this research has identified elevated
expression of h2 and smokers and those
with chronic lung conditions such as
copd
which may help explain why the cases in
these subpopulations have experienced
more severe symptoms and worse
outcomes than other populations
our other genetic analysis technologies
are also used in vaccine research with
real-time ccra is being used to verify
ngs or microarray gene expression
results
container sequencing and fragment
analysis being used for a confirmation
as well as cell line authentication and
genome editing analysis
vaccine research is often performed as
cultured cells obtained from major
repositories of
fellow researchers an estimated fifteen
to twenty percent of the time
celsius and experiments have been
misidentified or cross-contaminated with
another cell line
although major repositories now
authenticate cell line identity
many are calling for all researchers to
test and authenticate cell lines
identity using standard genotyping tests
such as str analysis this is something
that can be done with our solutions cla
identifier plus direct kits on our
biosystem genetic analyzers
finally for genome editing applications
around vaccine research standard
sequencing can be used to access genus
css genome
editing efficiency
now i'd like to talk about our second
application area host genetics and
population genomic studies which is the
search for potential close contributors
to far cov2 successibility in the hopes
of finding genetic markers for proton 19
progression
and biological insights that might point
to potential drug targets
when a population is challenged by
pathogens
individual responses can vary greatly
depending on their past exposure to
infections
environmental and socioeconomic factors
as well as their genetic backgrounds
we expect that the genomic leave
inherited from our parents will carry
common mutations but slightly modify our
proteins essential to our defense
against
infection so this is what we're aiming
to study in host genetics and population
genomic studies
research and hosts genital v2 infection
requires deep insight
into genome-wide interactions with the
virus these studies require a whole
genome technology
to understand the human genetic
determinants of covan 19's successive
body
severity and outcomes post genetic
variation to stratified populations by
risk to manage disease
improve outcomes and contribute to
global knowledge of biology as far as
positive infection and disease
i finally found the coach in to develop
research hypotheses for both drug
repurposing
and identifying drugable targets so
there's really an underlying need for a
lower cost
rapid whole genome technology such as
microarrays that can offer dense
coverage of genes
relevant as far as kovic infection and
medication management
to support this research we're launching
a new acting human genotyping array with
the sarah cov2 research module
that covers various genes and pathways
that are implicated in startup cov2 host
genetics
in addition the array has a large glass
module over 820 000 markers
they can serve to conduct association
studies to understand
the interactions with underlying
conditions and this is something that's
available to pre-order now
one example of research to understand
human genetics and psychology to
infection risk lies within the uk
biobank
study our 500 000 samples were processed
in just 18 months on the applied
biosystems acting platform
some recent insights were more recently
pulled from this data and published
that implicate that indicate
epidemiological relationships between
hypertension produce pulmonary function
and pneumonia
which can help identify people at risk
for adverse outcomes from thyroid cov2
infection
also the uk biobank dataset was used to
evaluate the relationship
between host genetics and antibody
response uncovering novel genetic
determinants of viral antibody response
in addition human genetics including
genetic analysis for the immune system
plays a critical role in host response
to pathogens
as we previously reviewed when
discussing vacuum research
analysis of the human repertoire enables
understanding of additional factors that
also influence the variance of infection
with end-to-end targeted engineering
solutions that include a robust and
differentiated information suite for
analysis of t-zone v-cell receptor
sequencing
populations can be studied to identify
biomarkers relevant to our opportunity
to infection progression
or potentially to help predict response
to future therapy
in fact blackwell park comprehensive
cancer center has announced that they
will be using their portfolio tpr and
vcare assays that they just described to
investigate biomarkers to help predict
who is likely to develop
severe disease and to investigate the
potential for biomarker
signature based on t-cell and v-cell
receptors and blood samples
this is a critical area of cov2 research
where much
information remains to be discovered and
what potential
impact on the way you move forward in
this crisis
so before we wrap up i wanted to say a
few words about our service and support
to help keep you running
throughout the current coronavirus
outbreak
we provide remote support and monitoring
options to help you keep your
instruments up and running even when
travel may be restricted
so we can help you by including
automated reality and desktop remote
support
we have remote monitoring services
throughout cloud-based instrument
connectivity
so that you can stay connected to your
instrument
in addition we have interactive
self-paced education
which is a great way to be learning um
during this time
finally in closing at thermal fischer
scientific our mission is to enable our
customers to make the world healthier
cleaner and safer
the global proven 19 outbreak is a
powerful reminder of the importance of
that mission
we're profoundly aware of our obligation
to continue supporting
you our customers and leverage our
capabilities to address this rapidly
evolving public health price
and we'll be continuing to do so with
our solution
with that i wanted to thank you for the
opportunity to speak today
you can learn more on our website about
what i talked about today
under thermofisher.combiler or
thermalfisher.com
thank you
thank you dr fumusa
for the outstanding presentation we will
now move into
the live q a of this presentation
as a reminder please submit your
questions
via the q a box and we'll look into it
there are several questions coming
through now
how about the first one
is the b cell receptor and or t cell
receptor sequencing
applicable for a mouse its
mouth splint tells the right cell type
what is the minimal amount of samples
required
the dna or rna so it looks like a series
of questions
regarding the b and t cell receptor
sequencing
and yes so we do have mouse athletes
available
for the bcr and tcr sequencing actually
we have human and mouse
you can use either or both dna and
rna and you can go down to the nanograms
of nucleic acid input as the minimal
amount
blood is really the common sample type
that people are using with this
thank you the second question
we have here is the star call 2
array currently available for ordering
yes it is it is available to order today
um
you can contact your local sales rep um
you can visit the booster exhibit hall
here
get some more information and you can
also go to
thermofisher.com m a coronavirus and
you'll be able to
fill out a form there also to get more
information about the array
more ordering information about the
array
thank you so dr i think the next
question we have here coming in
what populations are covered on the
array i reckon they are referring to the
microarray
uh yes okay if this is referring to the
accident stars kobe 2
array and this array covers um the five
ancestral population so european
uh agnes american african south asian
and east asian populations
and it also covers the 20 26 population
from the thousand genomes
project and there are markers covering
multi-ethnic populations as well
so let me see our next question
here is um you mentioned
that uh there is a potential role
for the gut microbial in the
pathogenesis
of cycle v2 virus can you elaborate on
that
uh yeah this is still an area of very
active research so there's a lot that
still needs to be learned
there have been a number of recent
publications studying the correlation of
gi disorders
with symptom severity and yet other
studying the impact of
probiotics in these cases as well it
does seem that there's an association of
immune factors known to be elevated
during stomach inflammation
that correlate both with gut dysbiosis
and severity of symptoms
but the mechanisms are not yet well
understood
interestingly there are other studies
showing the impact of specific gut
microbiota and response to vaccine so
this is an area of research that will
also be important for understanding the
potential use of
therapeutics or vaccines as well
sounds like a research worthy area to
look at
let me see the next question we have
here is
which of the platform would cater
to the investigation of inter individual
differences
in response to the viral infections such
as
subcofu and how can we put it in
relation to individual hra typing
yeah i don't know if we've looked at
that specifically yet not that i'm aware
of um
but i think that you could use a thing
or sequencing a fragment analysis
um platform like you do with hla typing
such as a
such as the seek studio genetic analyzer
to potentially look at that but i don't
believe it's something that
that we are investigating currently
thank you um the next question we have
here is uh more on vaccine development
here
can we use uncle my immune repertoire
sequencing
for developing monoclonal antibodies for
star called v2
uh i i'm not sure i'd have to look into
that one
no worries
so let us address one last question
before we transit to the next speaker
what we have here is regarding rna
expression array
is it designed specific to circle v2
infectious pathway
or is it designed to cover the entire
transcriptome
um it's designed to cover the whole
transcriptome all monthly md
arrays um not necessarily specific to um
florescov2 infection pathway but there
is some content on there since you're
covering the whole transcriptome
uh that would be relevant there
well thank you very much uh dr fumata
for all your sharings
on the various avenues to look at sarco
v2 research
because due to time limitation we won't
be able to address
all the questions that's being submitted
but
we will look into them and get back to
all our audiences about email
great thank you again for the
opportunity to present today
thank you very much
with that i would like to translate to
our next speaker
professor sorry alex sanderson
dr alexanderson is a veterinary
pathologist virologist and
epidemiologist or role in one
he specialized in molecular pathogenesis
detection and control of viral
infections
since 1982
has worked around the globe in denmark
us england
canada and since october 2015 he has
moved to australia
taking up the role as the professor and
director
of the geelong center for emerging
infectious diseases
it is a one health collaborative center
including greeting university barwon
health
university hospital
and viral australian animal health
laboratory
for complete biography on our speaker
please visit the tab at the top of your
screen
today he will share his work with us
on the use of employment panels to study
stuff called b2
and the host response to infection
if you have any questions arise during
the presentation
we encourage you to submit them in the
qna box
our speaker will address your questions
following his presentation
with that join me in welcoming dr
alexander
and i will turn the presentation over to
him
my name is sean alex anderson and i'm a
professor at deegan university
and university hospital geelong and
director of the g-long center for
emerging infectious diseases
i'm going to talk about the use of
ampliseq panels to study the science
kov2
and the host response to virus infection
the geelong center for emerging
infectious diseases is located in
geelong
in the southeastern part of australia
as you can see here uh to the right so
we are in the
very most southeastern corner of
australia
and about an hour's drive from melbourne
and a long flight from winnipeg in
canada where i worked
before
so our center is a one health center we
work on a healthy environment
healthy animals and healthy people
we are located at the university
hospital geelong campus
so we have very close contact to
clinicians
and it makes it also easy to get samples
rather quickly
from say patients or any other samples
taken at the hospital
as you can see up here this is our group
of people at the center and i
particularly want to acknowledge
anthony jamings which is a postdoc
working here
and also chaga basa which is a phd
student and they have done most of the
work that i'm going to talk about
today
so the aim of our center is through
collaboration and coordination to reduce
the impact
of emerging infectious diseases on human
and animal health
in australia and globally to do that
we have fairly nice fairly new
laboratories we started about four years
ago
this is at pc2 so not high containment
but we can work with clinical
samples and one of our partners is the
australian animal health laboratory also
located here in geelong and they have
higher containment so pc3 and pc4
if we need to do any work on on
pathogens that
require higher containment so a lot of
the work that we do at the center is
molecular biology
so sequencing pcr and so forth and down
here in the right hand corner
you can see our next generation
sequencer
the iron torn machine and jesse another
psd student
is getting ready to load that for some
next generation sequencing
so here decent we used three different
methods
from this generation sequencing uh
there's the empty seq panels that i'm
going to talk about today
they of course gives targeted sequencing
using amplification
with multiple pcr amplicons
simultaneously
it's fast and it's very sensitive but
you need to have prior sequence
information
and of course you need to have a panel
designed ahead of time
currently we use the ampliseq panels for
a human here virus so this is a
piconavirus and we've been working on
that for about four years now
it's a fairly small virus so we only
need 37 amplicons and this is a panel
that we have designed
ourselves and had quite a lot of good
success
with that panel we all have another
panel that's for antimicrobial
resistance
work there's 815 amplicons in that
panel and it's a panel from thermal
filter
and then what i'm going to talk about
today in particular is the sars kobe 2
panel which has 237 amplicons
getting the virus and another five
amplicon stock meaning
a human human genes as controls
we're also working on with thermo
fissure on an inflammation panel that
has 683 amplicons
and we are planning on using their
immune response and the t cell and b
cell receptor
panels as well so that's in the pipeline
in addition to the ambassador panels we
also do other types of next generation
sequencing
including total dna extraction and
sharing
that of course gives an unbiased and
more or less quantitative
uh reads but it's not very sensitive
we currently use that for antimicrobial
resistance for microbiome work
bacterial isolates and so forth and the
third method that we're using and have
had quite a
bit of success with as well and can
complement
the ampliseq panels is virus or particle
enrichment and unspecific amplification
of
all protected dna and rna in which case
we can look
pretty much for any pathogen in
particular viruses but other
microbes can be looked at as well as the
ribosomes from various microbes are also
concentrated and purified by this method
i should stress that all methods require
specific analysis of the sequence reads
and one thing with the embassy panel is
that the analysis is usually
easier than for the other methods
as i said we have been working on
another virus for at least four years
now
it's a paragon virus a small piconet
virus that affects
very young babies and more or less came
to
australia back in 2012
we need very accurate sequencing for
these viruses because we're basically
following them
by single nucleotide changes as you can
see here and we have had
pretty much outbreak since 2012 pretty
much every two years and as i said we
have
our own panels uh emphasis panels for
looking at this particular virus and we
need very
accurate sequencing as we follow the
virus as it evolves
with single nucleotide changes
coronaviruses and of course today we're
going to talk about the sars
kobe 2 and the alpha and the beta
coronaviruses so those are the viruses
that traditionally comes from bats but
there are other coronaviruses that we
have been following for some time
a lot of people look at bats and and and
switch hoe switching of bad viruses and
other mammalian
viruses but we have been looking quite a
bit on birds because they also have
coronaviruses
there's the traditional gamma corona
viruses which appear only to affect
birds but not too many years ago
another genus of coronaviruses were
discovered in birds called delta
coronaviruses
and it turns out that some of those
tesla coronaviruses can also jump
species so jump from birds
and they jumped into small carnivores in
asia
and and more recently into pigs and they
made it into north america back in 2013
2014
so there's some evidence that also some
of these coronaviruses
at least the delta coronaviruses may
also be able to jump into mammals
uh and and perhaps eventually into
humans
but today we are going to talk about
beta coronavirus so
most likely with an origin and bats and
we specifically going to talk about the
sars
kobe 2. as i said we have been looking a
bit
on these bird viruses the delta
coronaviruses and they are present
in australia and we can follow them and
they seem to be
in both in resident birds such as ducks
but also in migrating birds and we can
see that they actually interchange
over long distances and they migrate
over long distances and we can see that
we have
viruses here in the southern part
southeastern parts of australia
that are very very similar to viruses we
find in migrating birds
up in severe alaska and down the west
coast and the east coast
of the u.s so again birds can also
migrate over long distances and they can
kind of transmit these delta
coronaviruses among them
and as i said there is some evidence
that at least
in rare cases some of those delta
coronal viruses can also jump into
mammals
but today we are going to talk about
beta coronal virus and saskov2
specifically using the thermal fissure
iron ampliseq
sas cov2 panel so in terms of samples
so we we have the panel and
we have samples so the samples we have
been working on are they
basically left over overflow swap
materials so they're swaps
taken from individuals and there are
traditional kind of diagnostic samples
they're taking here in the greater
geelong area
and they're tested at the bound health
australian richest reference laboratory
or the australian clinical labs
so that we know whether they're
positives or negatives
but as i said there are routine samples
and they've been used for initial
testing
and they're also needed for future
studies so we have very small sample
volumes
and sometimes not optimal quality as
they've been tested several times and
maybe
frozen several times as well
so as we have very little volume we also
have to extract nucleic acids from
very small volumes and as we need them
for
several different studies and maybe
elude them in a higher volume that
you would normally do so so we have a
very low concentration of nucleic acids
and very limited sample volumes so far
we have collected 55
samples including 20 samples that are
positive or in the dubious range
so these are from kind of routine
diagnostic testing so many of them
are very weak positive
so we have attempted this far the
ampliseq sequencing with the panel
of a total of 15 samples so 14 positive
and a negative control
of the 15 samples two were not taken
further as they did not amplify with the
empathy panel and
there were two very poor samples so just
barely positive
by pcr so overall we have taken 12
positive
samples and one negative control sample
through ngs
and created a total of 58 million reads
on 530 chips
and i should say before i go through the
positive samples that the negative
sample
is negative as expected
of the 12 positive or weak positive
samples stupid samples
we have got near full length good
quality sequence from six of them
and they have been submitted to this age
so that's a global influenza and now
also coronavirus
database and partial sporadic sequence
of the other six the six samples that
only provided partial or sporadic
sequence
either had a very high ct so a very low
virus load
or for two samples which actually had a
low ct so
a high virus load and gave poor sequence
we now know that they're for example
handling and storage
so that we have degraded rna in those
samples so they still give
a good low ct in the pcr but the
sequencing give
short reads and we only get kind of
sporadic sequence coverage
so overall it works very well with good
quality samples
with a ct in our hands at a below 30
watt one
you can probably go above 31 if you have
good quality samples but as i said
we have only access to kind of used
well-used diagnostic samples and they
can be degraded
so we have submitted this work we have
submitted it to a journal and it's
available
in mid-archive you have the title there
sequence analysis of
travel related strategy two cases in the
greater geelong region australia
and as i said that is freely available
on mid-archive
give a bit more detail there of the six
good quality sequences that we assembled
from these samples
four of them were essentially full
length and they had a ct values or pcr
load of 18 to 31 so again
it's about having good quality samples
maybe more than having
a lot of virus in there one sequence was
missing
46 nucleotides so a small gap in there
as you have several amplicons
if you have a bit of degradation of your
sample maybe you might lose a little bit
of the sequence but as i said for four
of them or auto six
basically the complete sequence one
missing a little bit
and for one we had about 1.76
percentages of the genome reported as
ends
and if you look at key sata you will see
that that's not unusual
that you might miss a few bases along
the genome
as i said the good quality samples we
the panel provide length sequence
and is the only missing 42 nucleotides
at the five prime end
and 28 nucleotides and the polyetail
in the three parameters so this is where
the kind of the terminal primers are
located
uh and although you might get the
sequence as such
it's part of the sequence based part of
the primers and really you shouldn't
really trust them and and this isn't
more or less a general phenomenon and
you would see it places like this eight
that they usually uh mask or remove the
ends of the sequences
anyway since they are not usually not
reliable
assembly of our sequences was initially
done using the plugins so the torrent
irontorn plugins perma and kovit 19
annotates
snip plugins so those are the ones that
can give you
the differences of your sequence as
compared to
the reference and also assemble the near
full length
genome this is easy it works very well
however it only resembles good sequence
for high quality high coverage samples
and in in my opinion our opinion you
should
manually check it and you should trim
the ends and so forth so
it it does assemble near full length
sequence
of high quality but again i think it is
a good idea
to check it manually afterwards
so when when we assemble these sequences
we often use
other three programs we use free
programs such as
idv the integrated genomic viewer and
also mega
also another free program idv
is particularly suitable for this as you
can kind of get a visual
view of the quality of your sequence and
if you look here the the top
sequence here you see that there's very
variable coverage
across the genome and the reads are very
very short
so this is a poor sequence on a poor
sample
and we know the reason now we know the
reason why it gave poor sequence
which was basically because that sample
had been put in water
rather than in transport medium this is
the second one here
is a good sequence very good coverage
basically from one end of the genome to
the other one
good coverage and we see that there's a
few
sequence differences as compared to the
reference so from that one
you can assemble pretty much a full
virus genome
the two lower ones are also fairly good
quality but again
maybe not able to assemble the full
genome but very very close
to the full genome
then when you have sample the genome of
course you can use it for different
types of comparison either using ncbi or
various programs or downloading
available sequences and that's both next
screen
that skins8 and for sasko v2 there's
last time i looked about 50 000 year
full length
genomes available so there's a lot of
phylogeny and comparison you can do this
is just
showing a very simple comparison as we
were interested in seeing whether
the travel history of our individuals
our positive
tested people they have been traveling
so they were returned traveler we knew
where they had
returned from and using this type of
analysis we can then you look at whether
that fits
see the sequence of the virus with fit
with where people have been traveling
back from
and this particular individual that you
see here had returned from the united
kingdom
and the closest sequences are also the
sequences that have been deposited in
the database
from the united kingdom so this is just
to show a few examples
another one we know that it was a return
traveler
from germany and europe central uh well
europe in general and again the virus
is closely related uh to
viruses from well from germany and
netherlands
so again using the sequence the very
accurate sequence you get
you can start to look at these type of
things
just the final one so many things you
can do when you have assembled the wire
sequences
but of course you have to have accurate
sequence to look at these type of
type of analysis
so just to walk the end here i also want
to talk a little bit
about other panels so we're talking
about here the virus panels for the
south kobe 2
and the symbol of full length virus
sequences
from the same samples and i said we we
have very low volumes
so very little nucleic acids that we can
extract from these samples
but again using panels from thermal
fissure ampliseq
you can look at other things and here we
are looking at the host response
to the infection so we have a number of
positive samples that starts go with two
positive samples and a number of
south will be two negative samples and
these are swap samples
uh it's the same nucleic acids that we
use to assemble little virus
and we can look using the so-called amp
c
inflammation panel as to the host
response so here we have about 683
different amplicons of different genes
targeted by this inflammation panel and
i'm not going to go into details
but it's basically doing the same it's
amplifying
mission rna for these various
inflammatory
genes or genes associated with
inflammation
and we can then get reads next
generation sequencing reads that we can
then
look at the abundance of those reeds for
the various genes
in the various samples and compare them
and this is just showing a plot at the
top
and these other when we look at as i
said 683 genes
there's about 250 or 253 genes
in this particular swap samples that we
can detect by this method
and the applied here on the x-axis and
the levels
of them in individual samples up at the
y-axis
and you can see that certain samples
have certain genes
that kind of sticks out what is shown at
the bottom here
is uh around zero here is where
positive samples of size could be two
positive samples
and size could be two negative samples
have the same level
of these particular genes and again you
can see for south korea two
some genes are upregulated and a number
of genes are downregulated
in the south but with two infected
individuals this is something that we
started
very recently but it shows that again on
the small
channel volumes and even on these type
of swaps
you can start to look at the whole
immune response or inflammatory
response to the infection there are
additional panels that we are looking
into
such as the thermo fissure immune
response panel
and also the v-cell receptor and the
t-cell receptor panels
so that we can fully characterize a
the virus infection but also the host
response
to the infection
so at the very end here this might seem
complicated but
when we do the panel so when we do the
virus panel
looking for the full virus genome as it
turns out
the panel is designed to give the full
source cov2
virus sequence so the genomic sequence
of the virus
as it turns out as you can see here at
the left
corona viruses do have what's called the
leader
so for the south cov2 this is a
sequence of about 70 nucleotides at the
very five prime end
of the virus so the panel is designed so
that it has primers
in the leader and then of course it has
primers that sits
in the open reading frame one close to
those primers there
that are supposed to give a sequence
from the virus genome itself as it turns
out
the way the virus replicates in the cell
it makes what's called subgenomic rnas
and those sub genomic rnas which you can
see here on the right of which there's
10 supposed to be 10 we can only find
eight
in vivo but it can the virus can
probably make at least 10 of these
subname rnas
all the sub you know my rnas have a
common leader
so they actually have this five prime
leader
is connected to the various open green
frames so to in order for the virus to
make the spike protein for instance
or the various other proteins down here
in the three prime
third of the virus it needs to make
these subgenomic
rnas each of the subgenomic rna as i
said
has exactly the same sequence it's
basically this piece of the sequence
sitting in front of the gene so that
means that when you do every
sequencing or if you do epicon
sequencing
with primers that have sequences in the
leader
those primers would actually also sit in
what you see here as a black box
in front of each of the sharp genomic
rnas
these are genomic rnas was initially
thought to be
more or less unstable but it turns out
that they're fairly stable and
found when you and you find the virus
you will also find the sub genomic rnas
and with this particular panel and as i
said with any amplicon based
strategy for which you have primers in
the leader
and if if you then also have downstream
primers that sits in these individual
genes
which you will have because the amplicon
based
methods basically cover the whole genome
so you will have a reverse primer
sitting
pretty much in in any part of the genome
and you're going to have
these early primers forward they would
sit
in front of each of these optimal rnas
so as it turns out and what we found out
fairly recently
is that when you use the amplicon
sequencing you do not
only get the virus genome
but you can actually also map the
individual
subname rnas it's this requires slightly
different
analysis of the reads because when you
normally assemble it
you assemble it against a reference and
you're going to assume that it's the
virus
the full virus genome but because these
are kind of
put together by a specific open reading
frame
and a leader sequence it just requires a
slightly different
analysis of the sequence reads but you
are able to actually find the various
subgenomic rnas
and the abundance of those rnas in
exactly the same panel run so it's
basically using the same panel it's
using the same data
will give the full virus sequence but it
will also give the presence
and abundance of these subgenomic rnas
so i only have left to give the
acknowledgement in particular to anthony
and targa for doing the work
to other people in the lab to the
clinicians and the diagnostic labs to
thermal fissure
and to the various people that have
funded our work
thank you
thank you thank you dr alexander for the
outstanding presentation
we will now move into the live q a
portion
of the presentation as a reminder
please submit your questions by the q
a box and we'll look into them are a
number of questions
coming through right now our first
question is
why is there a need to use a
panel to conduct a study instead of a
whole genome
sequence
so well as i explained with our samples
at least
we have very little sample material and
in many of them
we have a very low virus load so in
order to get
enough or to get good sequence covering
the whole virus
you usually have to amplify
so dr alexander said i noticed that one
of the method that was used was ultra
centrifugation
is there any downside of using that
uh well one of the methods we use that's
not for the patent that's not
all that's for the unbiased sequencing
and and concentration of virus particles
or particles
we use ultracentrifugation for the for
the panels or the emphasis panels or
or panel amplification we do not use
other certification
thank you going to the next question
how important are these epidemiology
studies
in driving lockdown decision for in the
country
we will be processing more of these
samples uh
as a requirement for the national
program to actually look into
making any decision
well for the national program it's
entirely based at least to my knowledge
it's entirely
based on pcr testing so diagnostic pcr
testing
and then decisions made from that so
you know the studies that we do in terms
of the specific
virus sequence or say the inflammatory
response
has not have any impact on the actual
testing and
response
okay the next question um is it known
that that other coronal virus present in
animals
apart from that that can affect humans
well well uh it's not known that there
are any but i mean several of them of
the ones we already have
they did not all come from bats or maybe
they originally came from bats but
maybe they went through rodents or say
bovines or cattle so clearly these
viruses can change
host so they may be able to get into
another mammal
maybe initially and then eventually into
humans
so it may not happen just kind of right
away
and they may not be present in a in a
bath at this
moment but there are clearly viruses in
bats and
perhaps also in birds that eventually
given the right opportunity and maybe
bad luck
or good luck from the virus point of
view may make it into
another mammal or into a mammal if it's
from a bird
and then eventually it may end up into
humans
thank you so the next question we have
here is more on public health awareness
one health has long been a global
advocacy
in terms of viral uh
surveillance and interrelationship
between animals
human and environment from your step
from a point of view how can we help to
strengthen this public awareness
well i think well being a veterinarian
and
having worked with animals for many many
years and in the one health
space one health and kind of things
jumping from animals to people is not
new at all and and as a veterinarian is
something we've been concerned about
for years and years and years i mean
basically started with bovine
tuberculosis and brucellosis
more than 100 years ago so i think from
the veterinary
profession or the veterinary point of
view
it's a no-brainer in a sense but i think
to convince
the human health side or the public
health side because it seems to be
forgotten every time
it seems to be remembered every time
things happen
but then in the meantime in the interim
or between
episodes it seems to be forgotten and in
in reality
humans are just another species
everything else
i guess you call it animals but it's
kind of a it's a it's a
it's a continuum of all kind of species
including humans
and clearly we are not that different
probably continuing from the the one
health uh conversation
do you reckon that uh because one health
is more of a
global initiative in the regional levels
such as asia specific
because we have different dynamics is
there
a need to have some kind of organization
or consortium that actually advocates
the same message from one health
i think it would definitely be an
advantage to have some organization that
can
well a can give the message but it's
also about having
people actually work closely together so
that maybe
let's say i represent more than the lab
side or the laboratory side of things
that very often you could have a better
integration
between human public health and animal
health
because the methods and the knowledge
are often very very similar
and quite often what we know from the
animals field both in terms of
diagnostics but also in terms of control
and in terms of maybe action can be
to a certain extent be kind of extended
into when we have a public health
emergency so i i think there is a lot
to learn or at least a lot to transfer
or to interact
between the animal health side and the
human health side both in terms of
lab diagnostics but also in terms of
knowledge of infections because many
times we think
that you know infections in people are
very very special
but very often there are very similar
infections in animals that we already
know of
and and if we talk coronaviruses we have
known about coronaviruses
well in people but we known about them
in in animals
including livestock for for many many
years
so it sounds like such an organization
does not exist yet
but does it uh exist in the national
level australia austral
asia um
[Music]
does it exist i mean well we have the
geelong center but that's a fairly small
center
and i think most people do talk about
one health
but to actually get it to work it's very
difficult because
there are clearly silos human health
silos and
and maybe also animal health silos i
think from the animal health side and
from the veterinary side
we're very prepared to work with the
human health side
but as i said and maybe that's just my
personal view
it's more often more difficult to get
the human health side
to actually accept or maybe come to the
animal side at least in peace time
and by peace time i mean when we don't
have an outbreak
good point the next question i have here
is uh
more on the viral loader that looking at
the sub genomic regions
in star core v2 correlate with viral
load
well indirectly the more viral load you
also seem to have more soft genomic
rnas so it's not
i think the the message here is more
that they're there the sub genomic rnas
are there which
may be slightly a surprise but they seem
to be there
even late in infection and from at least
for our samples
when we can detect the virus or the
virus rna
excuse me we can also detect the sub
genomic rna so
there is indirectly accolation the more
virus
at least in our samples you also have
more of the sub genomics
but even when you have fairly low level
of virus
you can still detect them at a low level
these subgenomic rnas
probably the last question i have here
is um
you spent a bit of time on the lead
sequence that was
on the last slide
what do you think are the impact of this
elite uh sequence
uh in terms of uh phytogenesis or or
even viral load uh
because these things are very
interesting finding
yes well so the leader sequence all the
coronaviruses have
have a liter sequence around the 70
nucleotides long and it can vary a
little bit maybe from 50 to 100
nucleotides and it's not only the corona
viruses also other viruses have the same
and i guess they need to have it in
order to make these subgenomic
rnas and they evolved kind of into
having a very
very nice way of making their sub
genomic rnas
and if they couldn't so if they didn't
make those they wouldn't make the
proteins from all from the whole three
prime
end of the virus so it means that it
will not make any spike protein which
causes the receptor binding protein and
also the nuclear protein which is a very
important protein for the coronaviruses
so
yes they have the leader and it sits
there and and i guess in the genomic
rna it may look as if it's not really
doing anything but it is actually very
important because it has to
sit there in the front of each of these
sub genomic rnas and it's basically
a way that the virus at least indirectly
makes its messenger rnas
sub genomic rnas and also the whole
virus rna
are basically looking like messenger
rnas so it
may kind of partly fool the cell
to think it's a it's a normal cellular
messenger rna
because well i don't have time to get
into that but it's
it's not just the leader but it's the
way it makes these subgenomic rnas and
it's also
kind of the way that it gets proteins to
sit on it so it basically
a when it's replicating and making them
it's hiding it from the cell
and when it gets into the cytoplasm in
order to make proteins
it's more or less looks like a normal
cell or mason journey
so the the cell in a sense is getting
tricked into not
responding with a severe immune response
thank you dr alex anderson um
i think that's all the time we have for
now however
thank you uh and as a final reminder to
all our audience
of any questions that were submitted and
not answered today
uh we will uh get back to all of you
by email and i would like to thank dr dr
alexander for his time
for sharing his voice on his insight on
the sarco v2 and the epidemiology of
that
so thank you for all the questions
and all the speakers for spending their
time with us we will now
take a 15 minute break before we start
the next session
check out various application tracks
that may be of your interest
at our booth please go and have coffee
this is the booth
learn more about exciting promotion that
are available to you
where you can ask questions to our
thermal officials
representative at each of the segment
booth please also participate
the scavenger hunting game look for
icons in the environment
to win prices there will be a pop-up
survey
appearing in a minute please help us to
complete the survey
and thank you and look forward to speak
to you again
15 minutes later thank you very much